Je suis le chronométreur Raymond Leon Je suis Will
Salas Je sais où avez-vous trouvé qu'un
homme nommé Henry Hamilton m'a donné plus d'un
siècle, il a dit qu'il n'en avait plus besoin
c'était un cadeau Je ne suis pas un voleur
mais bon si  vous cherchez
des tuiles volées peut-être devriez-vous arrêter
tout le monde ici je vous vois parler de
justice je suis un chronométreur je ne
me préoccupe pas de la justice
je ne me préoccupe que de ce que je peux
mesurer secondes minutes heures je garde le
temps dans lequel le temps est  les mauvaises mains
Silvia fais ce que je dis et va avec les
gardes oh pour l'amour de Dieu père il y a
une armée dans cette maison si nous ne pouvons pas empêcher
un homme de nous tuer nous devrions nous tuer
toi